what effect is this gonna have how would
you would it it's gonna be reflected
yeah
across the y-axis stuff horizontally so
I'm gonna get this side okay
instead my asymptotes to I'm gonna be
able to same spot and everything is
going the other way okay which means all
those points I had before there's minus
one lens to this one so posture good
okay now I've applied a couple of
different things here so what does it
mean what does it mean good
I'm gonna say vertically that's okay
yeah but it Mississippi with so what
have I got here my axis is going to my
center that teeth I'm gonna go in much
the same spot I'm gonna go across one
that way for all of my features
including my asymptotes and my
intercepts right so there's one and now
I'm at two but now I'm going to do that
vertical flip instead of increasing this
graph is decreasing it's going downwards
like this okay there you go now last one
be careful with this one again I could
clean it I could kind of brute force
this right now I can just put in some
points and then I can get something out
but using all of this language and
geometric structures we already know
what can I do in this okay so you can
see I'm factorized okay yeah good so
having written it like this
have you written it like this I see two
things number one there is a there's a
stretching and compression thing that
happens can you see that okay so that's
checking compression is it's this one
right see how it's that it's it's bad
okay so it's been squashed in okay but
then not only am I going to be
compressing it I'm also going to be
shifting it how far am I shifting it I'm
shifting it one not two can you see that
right it's not really expose to it
actually it's one of the factorization
helps you see that okay so therefore
we're going at this guy
because I've shifted one to the left or
right left therefore where should my
asymptote be x equals minus one
yep okay then because I've got the
compression right instead of having my
vote here it's gonna be closer into the
asymptote right so instead of the
internet being at the origin it's going
to be closer oh that's bad yeah that's
right there we go it's gonna be - off
and sure enough just like before you can
put in why cuz you're right you go ahead
and solve and you'll get - uh-huh
when we do X equal zero
nice that's gonna be log base two all -
which is just one okay now it's worth
mentioning you sort of don't need to
have a point to scale here because
you've got two points two points is
sufficient the scale but just for the
sake of completeness whoops I forgot it
over here what would I put over here
guys suggestion three and that comes
down to negative one okay and then over
here I'm gonna suggest you could do it a
few couldn't you if I do I want a value
in here that's gonna give me a power of
two up here right does that make sense
cuz if I get like two or four eight I'll
get an easier job right I'm gonna put an
x equals what's the smallest one one cuz
that'll make for here right so if I say
one they only careful here don't you
that's gonna be too